my name is Koli Andrews GSP class of
2009 My partner and I started a firm
called Pacific light partners and all we
do are invested in support search fund
entrepreneurs the search one models has
its roots here at Stanford and
fortunately it's a very fast-growing
part of the little entrepreneurial
universe the search on model is really
entrepreneurship through acquisition
it's an opportunity for individuals who
want to be their own boss but aren't
necessarily a start-up person to raise a
little bit of walking-around money to
conduct a thoughtful two-year search to
find a small business to buy usually
it's from an owner someone in their 60s
or 70s who wants to retire and doesn't
have a son or daughter that they either
want to hand the business to or would
like to take over the business and it
provides an opportunity for a recent MBA
graduate to step into the leadership
role and become the CEO of a small
profitable and growing company we
believe in backing smarts and hustle not
experience and the way we get around the
experience is by focusing on buying a
company that has its very strong
characteristics it's very healthy it's
unlikely to be broke in unlikely to be
run into the ground by a 30 year old
who's never run a business before and
when you have those ingredients at the
company level and you layer it on top of
that somebody who's inexperienced but
well-educated has a lot of hustle and
drive has turned down attractive offers
to go work at other big companies
because she or he wants to be in
business for themselves you really can
create an environment where a lot of
magical things can happen
some people just say you know what I
have to be passionate about the idea and
the product that I want to create and
therefore you know I'm gonna go start my
own business and that's that's just a
certain type of personality there are
those out there though who say you know
I'm not really that concerned so much
about the product the passion I just
love the idea of managing I want to be
in charge I want to make decisions I
want disproportionate responsibility
early in my career those are the folks
that end up going the search fun path
not necessarily the startup path there's
also a risk difference the odds of
success in the search fun world are
materially higher than starting your own
business you can they come in two phases
one you raise money to go out and find a
company and you have about a 75% chance
during a two-year period of actually
finding them buying the company they're
after once you buy the company you have
about a two-thirds chance sixty-seven
percent chance that you're actually
gonna be successful and make money and
there are investors out there that have
skewed the odds on both of those
situations farther up to the right to
the positive so when you walk it all
through you have a greater than a 50%
chance of being successful become a sino
CEO building a company and having a
financial outcome and a life experience
outcome that you want that's very
different than the startup risks where
it's much more boom or bust what we're
looking for when we find a new
entrepreneur or a new hunt repeated out
to us there's really two things one the
strategy that they're gonna employ to
look for a company to buy and the type
of company that they want to buy so that
gets to my earlier point about hey
buying a good business and a good
industry increases your odds of success
so if they're focused on that that's
great check the box then it gets to the
harder stuff which is the softer side of
the individual why do they want to do
this have they turned down other
attractive offers so they're really
demonstrating commitment to this path to
being their own boss the search fund
model is predicated on taking somebody
with high potential and surrounding them
with people that can help him or her
succeed if they're willing to listen and
take advice from those who have gone
down the path before them and avoid
mistakes otherwise might make that's a
good sign
we often get that question oh my gosh
you put a thirty-year-old in charge of a
company on day one
doesn't everybody flee for the exits and
the answer is no you know these are
small businesses the employees it's
important for them it's their job they
want to stay there and obviously you're
trying to minimize as much change as
possible particularly in the first year
so the transition is really do not do
nothing just listen learn make sure
you're buying a business that's going to
continue to move forward even while you
have this management change going going
on then what happens you wake up 12 or
18 months later and the entrepreneur
knows an enormous amount more about the
business and the industry and the board
that's been working closely with the
entrepreneur understands things much
better and you can begin to slowly start
to make changes to you know build out a
sales force and begin to attack a
different part of the market that you
weren't doing before bring in some
senior leaders to helpfully grow and
scale for the investor it's not a lot of
money up front to run risk on a high
potential individual so we're investing
30 40 50 thousand dollars for that
entrepreneur to have two years of runway
to go out there and find that business
okay and I know that 75% of the time I'm
gonna have an option to invest more
money into the company that actually
find and that's why you know I exist is
to invest larger amounts in the business
on behalf of our of our LPS
so you skew the risk materially and have
you know on the small dollar amount
there's some chance you're gonna lose
that but 75 out of 100 is still pretty
good and then you have a chance to
decide whether or not you want to invest
a lot more money once you have something
known which is a known business a known
history of profits and growth a known
industry and an entrepreneur that you've
been working with for 18 and 24 months
that you've gotten to know a lot better
than you did back at the beginning
every day you're waking up and it's a
new battle every day to find somebody
who will actually talk to you certain
entrepreneurs over the life of their
two-year search will reach out to
thousands of companies they'll have
hundreds of conversations hopefully
hundreds of in-person meetings but maybe
not even that tens of in-person meetings
to have a chance to buy one company so
it takes you know an enormous amount of
inner strength and conviction to wake up
every morning knowing that 90 percent of
your day is gonna be rejection to have a
chance at the end to achieve your goal
which is to become a CEO when you're 30
or 31 years old 1995 there were two or
three search funds raised roughly that
year plus or minus a year or two in 2005
it was more like 10 or 12 and in 2015
there will be over 50 search funds of
kamon raised so it is clearly now I've
gotten to a place where entrepreneurs
who want to be their own boss but
they're not a start-up person know that
it's a viable path to achieving their
goal and so therefore it's a super
exciting time to be involved in the
search one community and if you just
think about the number of businesses out
there that are owned by individuals in
their 60s and 70s the baby boomer
generation they have to find something
to do with their primary asset and a lot
of them love the idea of selling their
business to a younger version of
themself which is the search phone
entrepreneur